it is what protesters across the u.s.
have been demanding the officer who held
his knee on George Floyd's neck has been
arrested
former Minneapolis police officer Derek
Chapman has been charged by the hand of
a County Attorney's Office with murder
and with manslaughter as Minneapolis
streets still smolder following a third
night of riots the state governor is
hoping the news will calm the violence
in the streets Minneapolis and st. Paul
are on fire the fires still smolder in
our streets the ashes are symbolic of
decades and generations of a pain of
anguish unheard much like we failed to
hear George Floyd as he pleaded for his
life as the world watched it is my
expectation that justice for the
officers involved in this will be swift
that it will come in a timely manner
that it will be fair that is what we've
asked for governor Tim waltz also called
the arrest of a black CNN journalist and
his crew early Friday by state police
officers unacceptable I take full
responsibility there is absolutely no
reason something like this should happen
calls were made immediately this is a
very public apology to that team it
should not happen
I failed you last night in that in
Minneapolis riot police stand ready to
confront a community that feels it's
been betrayed National Guard soldiers
have also arrived in the city requested
by a mayor who's under pressure to bring
the violence under control
this was a police station in flames on
Thursday night as anger directed at
those who swear to serve and protect
escalated not far away more burning
shops looting and violence protests have
spread across the u.s. in Denver
demonstrators echo the demands for
justice already heard in New York and
Los Angeles anger over the treatment of
African Americans by the police is not
new but right now it is very raw in
Louisville and Kentucky the death of
George Floyd has reopened old wounds
with protesters demanding justice for an
african-american woman who was shot dead
by police two months ago
breathe it is this video of the last
moment of George Floyd's life a police
officer kneeling on his neck that is
driving the outrage President Trump has
weighed in calling the protesters thugs
and suggesting National Guard troops
shoot looters the Republican president
also took aim against the city's
Democratic mayor Mayor Jacob fry fired
back Donald Trump knows nothing about
the strength of Minneapolis we are
strong as hell is this a difficult time
period yes but you better be damn sure
that we're gonna get through this as the
protests and George Floyd's name
continue to grow the leaders of major
cities across the u.s. are hoping that
promises of swift justice will be enough
to calm tensions
so to put this all in perspective at
this time on the first night of the
protest there were 8,000 people filling
these streets now we've got a few
hundred they are here in violation of
the citywide curfew but they are
peaceful right now it wasn't much after
this just 24 hours ago it wasn't much
after this time that the police station
the third Precinct police station was
stormed and that's where the officers
came from who arrested George Floyd so
this is a completely different
atmosphere what happens if the National
Guard marches in that we don't know and
there's a lot of night left to go we'll
see what happens okay John hendren live
for us in Minneapolis
and thank you Dave picking as a board
member of the communities United against
police brutality and he says restraining
and retraining and institutional changes
are needed to address the underlying
problems within the US police force no
officer will ever testify against
another officer and so we see that not
just the one officer who had his knee on
his neck that is the grossest violation
but that three other officers did
nothing about it at the time when it was
clear to everyone else on the scene that
George Floyd was being killed that's
what really matters is the actions of
the officers and in all the deaths we
have seen in Minneapolis no officer ever
testifies against another so even if
their words are sincere it doesn't show
in the actions that we've seen here how
quickly the officers were fired was very
unusual I think part of that is due to
this incident being so so horrifying to
anybody who watches the video but
remember before that video came out in
public
the police information officer was
trying to claim that the officers noted
that he was having a medical incident
and they assisted him so it only when
the other video came out that they were
forced to tell the real story they lied
their original statement because they
thought they could get away with it the
people who are saying these things are
no more honest now than they were then
they just got caught so yes after a
particular egregious incident like this
there's got to be a lot of soothing
words but we need to see real changes
institutional changes changes that have
been promised to us after the previous
deaths and have never happened